que pueden dar información sobre el momento más seguro para comer.
Nuestra investigación indica que este simple comportamiento imitativo
entre peces de distinta especie en una misma red social
los induciría a comer más del 60 % de las algas.
Esto puede ser fundamental para el flujo de energías y recursos
a través de los ecosistemas de los arrecifes de coral.
Pero este descubrimiento sugiere también que la sobrepesca
--un problema muy común en los arrecifes de coral--
no solo elimina peces,
sino que puede romper la red social de los peces que quedan,
que estarían más ocultos y comerían menos algas
porque les faltaría información esencial.
Y de esta manera, los arrecifes de coral
se volverían más vulnerables de lo que actualmente se predice.
Notablemente, las redes sociales de los peces
hacen que la acción de un pez se multiplique entre otros
y de este modo pueden afectar arrecifes enteros,
que son fuente de alimento de millones de personas
y el sustento de la economía global de todos.
Ahora bien, este descubrimiento nos indica que debemos lograr
un mejor manejo sustentable de los arrecifes de coral,
pero también nos muestra
que los humanos no estamos influenciados solamente por la acción de otros humanos,
sino también por la acción de peces individuales
en un lejano arrecife de coral
a través de su simple comportamiento de imitación.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)